oh look a high-density streetcar Avenue
good choice
where's all the streetcars mayor you
suck sure to someone else you want I'll
just don't W I love the new buildings oh
you want some more medium-well customers
great well here's some parks I'll shut
your mouth and give me your money if the
mayor would actually listen to my
requests you would know that I just want
some industry zone oh great another
intersection what are you guys
protesting about now hmm too many germs
taxes too high it's really a rough job
being the mayor around here I'm out of
money
I'm out of money a nuclear meltdown not
enough educated workers guys have an
entire university to educate yourself
you're doing well I'll follow you and
I'll find out exactly what you're doing
Hollow
oh you're looking for a decent job you
came from the streetcar stop well maybe
you should go get a job at the nuclear
power plant I go to school you I can't
get to any shopping oh you guys care
about a shopping where's all the
shopping I got shut up about your
shopping where's all the shopping if you
mention shopping one more time I'm going
to hurt you
there's no shopping I don't know how
much more shopping I can give you I'm
moving out you're moving out no I'm
really moving out where are you gonna go
great a low density dirt road looks like
you have real high hopes for us mayor 31
deaths a day deal with it Strasbourg
Isle has 14 garbage trucks 16 recycling
trucks six ambulances not share four
all the buses way too crowded I'm
calling in sick to work today suck it up
and walk thanks for watching bye SimCity
players say I tried not to make any
server jokes because it's actually been
working now hope you guys enjoy my video
let me know in the comments below
something that I should have included I
know there's so many things and as I was
editing this video like I should have
said this I should have did this so look
forward to seeing all your comments and
if you haven't played SimCity um yeah I
don't know what to tell you because it's
for winning my life let me see was any
life is cooler than my real life yeah
I'm running late they sold
medium-density streets and I'm getting
nowhere it was such a i'm paying
ridiculously high taxes for this look at
all this traffic in screwed